two minutes ninety four players okay so
a lot of people entered about 25 more
people entered since I entered and the
average rating is about seventeen twenty
six time is the handicap the criteria
what you need to get into this
tournament is nothing you need to be no
no no level requirement
all right game time in less than ten
less than five here we go
hopefully my mouse is going to be
treating me well game time alright
double those points get that thing out
of there I hate that thing see five
quick resigning Oh what's eighty-three
doing ah that's a waste of time in this
Bishop I'm gonna kick it around D fives
coming with tempo now if they take
they're in trouble okay now my bishop
and my knight have some good
possibilities here on that f5 square
let's do this and then Bishop to e6
Queen Queen to c1 no way I'm not
allowing that pawn to fall no way Queen
up here or actually here or actually
let's do this it's a pretty committal
but I'm still gonna run with it that
LightSquared Bishop isn't around really
to do any damage to me just yet I'm
looking for this move next and this is
actually a bit scary uh-oh uh-oh I
thought it could be in some serious
trouble there let's shut down that I
might still be in trouble oh let's go
here
ma'am King up do I really want to do
King up let's try this this
oh no the pond just pushes oh I'm in
trouble already why is this happening I
need to get that night out of there I
was fearful of night takes on g5 I have
less than a minute oh man
is everything okay if I go here no way I
gotta hang on to my light-square bishop
I gotta hang on to that oh no I just
miscalculated
oh maybe they miscalculated this is not
this is not a good first game no way
it's dream of that I gotta get out of
this pin my king is ready to get
crunched knight c6 those are gonna be f4
played oh I gotta take that night I have
to take that night and run away with my
king if Bishop takes oh okay
my king has to run run King and where
you got to run to all right here I guess
but it still could be checked you're
under the corner
I can't move my pawn if I move my pawn I
get made it that's not fun man 53 52 52
39 seconds a queen trade I love Queen
trades when I have the worst King okay
let's do this I need some more trades I
could start pre moving a bit easier am i
up material not for long
okay they're investing quite a bit of
time here and they just blundered that's
what I needed I needed them to blunder
there we go no it's all coming together
okay now I could go fast okay I dodged a
bullet right there I think I was uh I
was cooked I think I was definitely
cooked on that one Wow and this is
definitely far from being up
a quick way and I was wanting a quick
win right there let's get that in and
then run my H pond down let's get that
and then it's just cut the King off
looking for me
stepladder name two three
my here's good back to tournament
somebody has five five two two a bunch
of two's somebody has somebody's already
playing their third game that I have two
games in who's this okay
water all right I can't see the rating
about seventeen and night e to so I
could support my Center and do what next
okay I've miss played that I shouldn't
have done that move I think a three was
correct there might be a sacrifice on
this square followed up with Knight g5
if you're on the stream before you'll
know what I'm talking about okay it's
there this is a nice combination to be
aware of clean coming out mates rat got
it or do I
Oh Queen takes pawn is that a save mmm
it might be oh oh man oh man man man if
I push the pond there's Queen takes here
let me give a check something something
has clearly gone wrong here let's do
this and then ah something went wrong oh
man
let's take care say what they want to do
I mean that was wrong on that it's not
turning out good what are they gonna do
Knight on e6 and I takes D is my queen
getting trapped or anything
oh man what do I do here I want to get
my rook doing something on a1 looking
for East six and Bishop to c3 my queen
could take g7 is my queen maybe getting
trapped in some variations I don't want
to allow oh wait a second this has to be
good there's got to be just takes here
takes here and then takes here check and
then comes back with another check I'm
gonna try that
oh oh oh man am I getting mated oh is
this me no my queen is around to watch
over that what's happening here I gotta
watch for me I'm on the Queen twice what
is the Queen gonna do Queen trade the
bishops thicker oh that's not me I was
ready to mate on that square let's just
take this night okay now things are
smooth oh wow that got really scary
right there for a second okay back to
tournament eleven nine six six and some
more sixes and some fives 23 minutes a
lot of time left
oh man that didn't work out okay so I
was a bit too quick to snip that pond on
h7 maybe I'm the breed the one who got a
hundred on his psychology test he told
me so in the twitch chat okay I gotta
watch out for the psychological tricks
that he might try to employ here okay if
you're curious about Bishop e7 instead
of Knight f6 watch the Geary Aronian
game YouTube video explains that a bit
and we're kind of entering that
territory right now so what now a6 b5
Bishop b7 c5 or this I'm still looking
for the c5 move am i a bit too late with
that we're gonna see are they gonna push
in the center ok c5 is in the position
opens up this might become an issue now
that dark square bishop what is it doing
to contribute to the position rook on CA
opposite the Queen bad things maybe
could be happening quick
pins pin night let's get this night out
efore is available Queen c7 my other
rook here the night is in a pin this is
what I was just talking about hit the
pinned piece pile up on the pinch piece
hitting the rook and the knight a third
time chop its material are they gonna
resign uh-oh uh-oh
that's just a piece no resignation no
resignation or even with time there's no
advantage with regard to time here one
minute 15 okay they're still going up to
the seventh you have a second maybe f2
just double up rooks make a flight
square for my king I'm going to do that
now and rip to c8 I'm on that Bishop
three times something has to be done
about that more to the point was
probably that move instead of the flight
square but I'm netting some more
material here with check and then I'm
going to push that night around
okay back to turn with a resigned twelve
eleven eleven nine eight okay twenty-one
minutes left
nobody has a fourth game in just yet so
a lot of threes and twos at this point
and there we go we are paired up let's
try now it's let's do King pawn okay so
I'm having to fight back timewise and
all these as usual and these kind of
tournaments oh now my queen gets a nice
central post okay is C five minute plate
I see c5 a lot but that's not a good
choice because d6 is then an issue or
maybe better said is just the the black
deep on would be an issue I didn't want
to play there and skip castled and maybe
could I get this in now let's do this
uh-oh I'm winning this this I got a fork
right now this is a quick win I got the
rook maybe resignation the Queen moves I
get the pawn and then the rope
let's take the queen first and then the
rook and then and then here and
something's gonna go down let's let me I
grabbed something I don't want that to
just happen for nothing they're all I
got the bishop now and are they gonna
get their Knight there I'm not allowing
it that night to get there that time
yeah okay let's get that night out of
there I don't want to deal with it and
chase it away some more I got these
squares covered my LightSquared Bishop
surround and I'm having trouble moving
my mouse so let's throw a check in here
and get my bishop out and do what next
chop here let's come back looking for c4
on the rook they should be resigned time
no no resign check nope
let's try this again no that should have
been me right there yeah we got it
there we go back to tournament 2019 1916
our more players entered there's a
hundred and twenty seven some people
must have been entering late 127 here
okay Sicilian and Grand Prix attack
they're running with Bishop b5 no
they're looking for d4 I have to strike
at the center if they're gonna build a
big center I have to strike at I think
this is a good reply right now light
square Bishop out my pawn is
contributing and now this is a nice post
for my knight I think f6 is also a
possibility maybe Bishop to this square
is good if they Castle a knight right
here and now if they Castle this is big
trouble for their dark square bishop
it's going to go down if they castle
here so now I hit this and I'm actually
crashing
a dark square so this has to be really
good here Bishop f2 is the only and then
I break down this structure win upon and
the light squares are very weak Bishop
getting to e3 in particular and I'm
going to throw in an in-between move as
well and then recapture make sure that
that King is out and about and now what
next just back my Bishop up to f6 if
it's hit by the knight and get my clean
up to d6 and get a pawn up to e5 I want
to keep pressure on H to get my rook on
f8 my LightSquared Bishop on g4 now what
Bishop on g4 we're up to f8 okay dark
square weaknesses have been created get
my Queen to g3 and get to h2 somehow
let's get this in and coming up 'if I've
okay I have a tremendous center right
here if I do play this my queen would be
pinned let's not do that let's get this
pawn push next okay here we go
even just this push and that's my plan
get my queen to g3 my Bishop to e5 right
here I could also be throwing in check
so this should be decisive Queen here
off for Queen exchange
there's even Bishop takes pawn the Queen
has to be challenged right now and
they're not being challenged so I'm just
gonna go with this this is check and I
got the Queen but I don't have to go
with that there's something even better
this is good I'm ready to take the Queen
and then mate now and if Queen takes row
King takes rook rook check King back to
g7 rook F to e3 and then I'm getting
through at that point still so you might
be seeing what I just said
rook check and then rook F - I got e3 at
the end of it okay that's what I was
just talking about now it's me back to
tournament 30 33 30 29 25 who is this
dr. meadow I played him in the stream
already I'm on this particular stream so
maybe we're gonna get paired up or maybe
not actually because
there are quite a few players in this
tournament 127 so oh the same thing
actually going on this guy right here
it's I played somebody with this already
when they play East six and g6 I could
get that f5 square under my control and
now I'm winning upon let's get that in
there what's going on here oh I'm in
trouble I got to play g3 if Knight h5 I
should have captured my bishop I thought
something was off with that and now
we're seeing it
ouch okay this is fun okay although it
is an extra pawn but Knight right there
now let's open it up I'm okay with that
I'm defending everything I got B to f2
covered and let's castle an opposite
sides I have the G file now to play with
let's get this in though f2 is falling
that's okay I should still have
something I'm on this point they just
dropped their night and I want to keep
the Queen's on the board I'm looking for
a quick mate well so much for that
change of mind although this is a nice
shot right here and we're gonna take and
then what is that oh that must have been
a mouse slip mate back to tournament
there we go 42 33 29:29 less than 15 or
about 14 minutes left let's still run
with c5 here c5 smith mora or otherwise
okay open Sicilian C an accelerated
dragon-type and still go with it are
they gonna still delay that capture
they're gonna target f7 I'll play ecigs
okay put a question to it captured
towards the center and let's have a good
reason not to and I really don't have a
good reason not to Knight g4 is
available I believe right now Knight g4
Knight takes Knight takes bishop I think
that's available right now if I
that correct Queen takes Knight takes
Bishop takes I'm on this I'm on c2 I
could be playing my knight back I think
this is not a good variation to go with
because of how they are able to respond
right there so this is a weird spot for
my knight and I have to capture like
this otherwise my queen is taken but I
do have this dark square Bishop still
around but what is my light square
Bishop doing that's a good question that
I do not have an answer to and I don't
have a good answer to that move either
I'm in trouble
ah man okay well what do we do what do
we do when are in trouble I'm not liking
this definitely not liking this oh man
I'm turning up so much time right now
what do I do
look at my Queen side it's garbage oh
okay I see something I guess I have to
get my queen over to defend Queen to e8
and let's stick around over here man oh
they're trading queens lovely I love
that okay I'm okay there's there's no
more attack against my king
let's get that rook out of there before
they get to h7 okay and now my king
isn't inconvenience now I can get my
light square Bishop out the tables have
now turned I'm hitting efore and I want
to stop this Knight from making use of
these dark squares so slowly I'm
regrouping my pieces and now I'm going
to well my Bishop is well placed on this
square hitting a two and I'm looking for
be for next b4 actually even a form it's
good a for it I'm a miss pawn past a
pond the night is a lacking good squares
I'm gonna throw this in and now get my
rook doing what next let's get this pawn
up I want to break open the this file
what is they're gonna do defend like
this or that I got the this file now the
knight is boxed out and they're in check
mate
yes it's remain it can only block here
so I dodged a bullet in that situation I
think of my opponent realized
if they were you know just keep the
Queens on the board right there right
okay back to tournament 56:47 4737 11
minutes left okay this guy what do we
have this guy is 35 points having a good
tournament here I'm gonna try something
like this let's see what they did
respond okay and they got a castle now
or never
okay let's chop that and then get my
night out
efore let's see are they gonna kick my
knight around that might kick my knight
around okay leave my light square Bishop
out and okay work this Knight into a pin
now what light square bishop exchange or
not maybe I still want to just pinpoint
this punt right here and I can add
another attacker to it I want to break
down this structure quickly and they're
ready to support it now with that
advance so let's turn my attention a
little bit over here and stop the knight
from getting to h4 that could be very
strong I think this is a good spot I
think is g4 gonna be chief five minute
plate if g5 then eventually I could get
this move in I want to I want to get
this okay let's block that up I think it
would be a bit too nuts to have that one
open up I think I'm on Bishop d1 okay
here we go and I'm looking for h h4 and
then get my knight okay now it's been
blocked up and I don't want to allow two
minor pieces to capture through on that
I need to hold that somehow and okay
it's he comes f5 what am i doing how do
I get castle my pond is ready to fall I
got to defend that guy now I get to get
my knight here okay I'm seeing a way to
regroup now my bishop up and queen here
castle let's do this and get my rook
over here if the Queen attacks it okay
and now what get my knight where get my
knight where I want to get castle too
quickly if the bishop backs up what do I
do about defense of this pawn like just
like that what is my light-square bishop
doing now
oh I got a defender with my queen I
don't know how I'm holding this one
together okay I have some defense now my
knight to h2 breaking this down Oh
oh no they're breaking me down oh man
okay let's try this
look at these Knights this is not where
you want your Knights and Chad's Knights
on the edge both actually both sets and
Knights around the edge Queen exchange
could really go for a queen exchange
oh what a smooth move right there I
would end up in a fork if I took it and
now that night is coming there oh I got
a guard that square I'm gonna take it
now I think I have things defended I got
a runaway of my king and they're not
gonna let me do that oh man okay f200
run I just got to run run 13 seconds I'm
in a fork oh my queen is it okay um how
do I save this I'm gonna be sneaky take
my queen no they're not taking my queen
let's take this what am i doing I have
to be able to save this chop that I'm
getting mated seven seconds uh how do I
defend I'm beat em beat em beat em beat
AHA this is mate no it's me oh man
61-59 56 54 I dropped back I'm not in
first ah okay I'm getting this one
though I'm coming out swinging right
here I'm going I'm going down swinging
oh man why couldn't I weasel away from
that when I was under pressure so much
that f5 break d5 okay here we go
and start pushing my opponent around a
little bit there we go and what next
let's try it out and okay this is the
light square bishop light square bishop
where does it want to be
queenside castle Bishop to d5 here we go
you got everything covered let's get
that out of there and actually I'm not
going to Castle queenside and maybe I
should have oh man oh man I'm gonna try
this it's gonna look weird but oh why
didn't they just take um why don't they
just take my queen I wanted them to take
my queen I had something planned if they
did that I felt like I could put a lot
of pressure on them if they if they did
that move so now what I got a regroup
here this is not turning out good not
here I just take it are they gonna fall
for it that's great okay I'll take that
and get my king over here okay
so I was being a bit sneaky on that one
let's go here upon pleasure I'll just
take there we go let's get out of that
fork first though and watch over that
pun so my rook could get that pun
actually let's do this and then let my
King get out of the pin there we go got
some coordination now double the rooks
next my Knights watching over that
Bishop as well no resignation I need a
resignation please just resign oh wait
Bishop takes okay I still have support
for I should probably get out of this
pin that's usually a good idea get out
of pins in chess
how about run my King up on my king up
should've went to the other square
getting out of the pin now we're looking
for were doubling up on the second
double up my knight is here to defend I
could block
rook check I block with my night here we
go I'm breaking the main three three
threat million three trap check let's
throw this in first at that are they
gonna double up Brooks let's give a
check and then bump over here guard that
for just a second and then after rook
takes pawn that can't be defended here
can it let's do this
and then this and now they're in trouble
can't defend this no resign
that's me back to tournament 70 somebody
has eighty one eighty one seventy four
seventy one seventy for me I need to get
this one quick I think okay there's only
like a couple of time for a couple more
games ah man that loss really set me
back okay I got a I got a try for the H
pond get that age con rolling here we go
oh I miscalculated Knight takes pawn is
good the Knight takes pawn is still good
oh man
okay night each where let's do this
Bishop h6 I need to get rid of that dark
square Bishop fast this is not turning
out great I'm dropping that pond too I
could work with the healthly get my
Queen on d4 let's Preem of that I don't
have anything else and yeah there's
gonna be trouble for me now Bishop takes
Bishop Queen takes bishop bishop takes a
- I can't play like b3 - traffic as my
nights hanging but this is a different
story I think because of what I'm gonna
try it it's a bit crazy I think Bishop
takes is still fine Queen check King D -
I'm looking for a rook e1 then can I get
that in
please let me just get that in I am in
trouble oh man I think I just have to
take that I've seen something where I
just I felt the need to just take that
and now maybe I could be trapping the
Queen somehow can I get that clean
trapped there's gonna be a clean check
my king can run over in this direction I
think it should be safe but we will see
I think I need to grab that pawn
let's grab some material back I want the
Queen's to come off can I get the
Queen's to come off here Bishop c4 no b5
oh man
okay I gotta break the pin with these
Queens off man Knight g4 is gonna be a
killer absolute killer how did I
dislodge that Queen
uh I I didn't want to give up my light
square bishop that's why I went with
that how do I defend this I gotta get
rid of that night I think Oh
oh man run King again
is this working out please just say it's
working out somehow do I have the
squares cut guarded that I need oh yes
is my bishop in position I can't take
with my King otherwise night there is a
fork I think I have defended okay let's
come back I have a good I have a good
position now I think rook here and then
let's um not um fall to afford 51
seconds okay a little bit more
comfortable now now get my rip out in
this direction here we go
I want to pinpoint that beep on that's
the plan pinpoint the beep on and am i
falling for Forks no take my bishop okay
now my King has in my I have more active
rook let's get this in a two-to-one
majority
and let's get my ruck a little bit more
active what's happening here pawn push I
give check I could just take that pawn
what are they doing now I could give
check to the queen I have a two to zero
majority perpetual check is that what
they're going to do
now let's push my pawn push it again
let's get behind that pawn and then what
are they gonna do I need that I need the
help of this one as well
ah
are you kidding that was the end of the
tournament ah man what a pathetic way to
end ah man sixth place ah that one that
set me back was just too much to handle
I went nowhere there's not enough time
on the two minute ones the one minute
ones are much quicker you could get a
lot of games in 94 blasts Pacha's got
velm
dr. meadow Congrats dr. meadow fifth
taking fifth good sin tobik scoopa Renny
boy AB good games off man